Marisa is with us in New Jersey
hi Marisa how I gave hi good how are you
good how can I help
I'll try to be quick my husband and I
are both 31 we have two little boys 4
and 3 years old ever since they've been
born we've been hero to save the Earth
Day money and events and we've got up to
30 K $30,000 in three years well we are
only good as a car loan and the balance
right now is 32,000 so I had this
brilliant idea today of just using their
money which is just sitting an account
doing nothing and applying it towards
its car loan but I have this guilt
what's a household a little bad you over
a hundred fifty okay okay and I'm still
a little bit confused the math doesn't
work for me a three-year-old and a
four-year-old ER up to $30,000 and
birthday money incomplete
family members $1,000 you know we hope
we give birthday parties a restaurant
that we we pretty much when we put into
the restaurant we get back and guess
baptism parties birthdays Christmas yeah
we're very blessed I could say I guess
yeah it's just an unusually large amount
from a birthday gifts and Christmas
gifts for a three-year-old it's just
doesn't it's just I mean just the
baptisms alone they both got $5,000 we
spent five thousand they've got backside
I'll get it every time okay so you spent
$5,000 on what it was just her
restaurant money and okay
all that so you broke even on this deal
so to speak yeah pretty much
yeah well I would stop that I'm spending
$5,000 on a kid event
we don't yeah yeah I think that's party
foul yeah you're broken in debt now so
you can't do that
so no I wouldn't clean this out I mean
it is really your money because you
spent five thousand dollars in order to
put five thousand into their account so
it's almost as if you put the money into
the account but you know I probably
would just leave it alone and I would
roll up my sleeves and get on a real
tight budget and pay off your car you
only owe 30 grand on it and you make 150
tighten up your budget all right yep
real tight all right real real real real
real tight and that includes no more
$5,000 baptisms or birthdays yeah for
three-year-olds okay you can do it you
can do it it'll work for you I promise
hey thanks for the call